généralement il y en a toujours un peu
qui brille sur elle c'est soit des
diamants soient des pailles est solide
avec mais en bo1
si vous si vous la prenez dans l'état y
en a pour deux barres en pleine forme
moi ici c'est en pleine forme
oui alors est-ce voir il ya un truc à
changer encore vous avez fait vous avez
fait un truc là bas j'avais fait mon
petit mais au petit en injection là et
là j'ai fait le haut maintenant et les
lèvres ça va occuper les trois jours
gardé les épées à trois jours ça va un
petit peu dit tout le temps que sa peine
ne vous reconnais pas arrêté d'en finir
en 2021 prométhée nos elle vous arrêter
des travaux sont certains mais c'est
beau section sait rien n'y fait pas très
sérieux
c'est un petit peu gonflé non c'est bon
vous avez 2 2 c'est surtout à
l'impression des lèvres bougent tout
seul
[Applaudissements]
sur l'élan